and now we have this from timcast.com
supporters double down on fetterman
accused critics of ableism and bullying
did you guys see the view clips
when they were like I thought the
Hippocratic Oath was due no harm Dr Oz
was bullying fetterman bullying he was
having a debate it's a political debate
he's supposed to be like you're wrong
John at any point did Dr Oz say
fetterman has brain damage no what are
they talking about these people have
lost the plot they're willing to they're
willing to put in a guy who clearly his
brain does not work welcome to Modern
politics I suppose they hate you so much
they and and I mean it's I'm not trying
to there's not an emotional day or
anything it's factual they hate
Republicans they hate Trump they hate
Maga to the degree that they would vote
for someone like John fetterman did you
watch the debate oh I absolutely watched
the debate it was it was tough to watch
yeah I mean you know we're talking about
somebody that's gonna be one of a
hundred senators in the United States
Senate potentially that said he's going
to vote you know to break the filibuster
to end the legislative filibuster and
this is someone who cannot answer a
question on his point of view for
fracking and explain were you lying then
are you lying now or did your position
evolve we got no answer I mean we got a
long pause no answer and for people to
say well it's it's ableist I mean the
same people that said you know if when
Mike Pence was debating Kamala Harris
you know if he challenged her on
something well then that was man's
planning right it's the same thing if
you're a conservative and you actually
argue your points and they can somehow
you know turn it into well we really
can't argue with you with what you said
or that argument isn't really going to
work so we're gonna you know say you're
you're a mansplaining you're an ableist
um you're you're racist you're uh uh
insurrectionist whatever I mean just
pick from the the cookie jar of of
things to throw out there what is
ableism it's discrimination against
someone who is differently abled
I'm going to make an ableist t-shirt out
of all these discussions about ableist
two plus two equals five you ableist so
it's I'm gonna be thinking about like a
disability shirt that only has like one
or no sleeves
well as I understand ableism it's I
wasn't supposed to be a joke I'm like
are there people who have like one arm
you know do they wear shirts with an
empty sleeve like what do other shirts
that just don't have one I mean that'd
be cool right it would be cool actually
able not ableless what's I guess that
yeah that's the thing they're still able
those people are still able the whole
disabled like yeah things might be more
challenging but you're still able right
you know you still got your abilities
but that's the PC idea the disabled just
referred to someone who has a disability
they used to call them [ __ ] I mean
the word they're called invalids yeah
the words have evolved over the years
George Carlin nailed it yeah you guys
ever see that bit where he's like
post-traumatic stress disorder we used
to call it shell shock but then the
words keep getting more and more verbose
the phrases get longer and longer he I
think he mentions invalid but then
people are like no no you can't say that
that means invalid we can't say that so
then they create new words like [ __ ]
but then apparently those become
offensive and now there's disabled
meaning meaning you have a disability it
just meant like you didn't have your
your hand was injured your foot was
injured your eye your ear because on
average a person has two eyes two ears
two arms two feet two legs Etc and and
now that's offensive so now it's you're
not disabled you're just differently
abled that's not true man come on this
PC is so dumb if you have if the average
person has two hands and then someone
loses a hand that's not differently
abled it's disabled I got no what's
what's the deal I guess if someone's
born with three hands they're more abled
whatever it just depends on how
society's geared to function because if
you have like 27 hands you're you're
that's a form of a disability because
it'd be hard to navigate well the PC
progression language you could climb
trees and stuff you nailed it right so I
remember 20 years ago I'm law school
reading the case Oliver Wendell Holmes
he's going through the categories of
mentally disabled people at the time at
the time which is you know the early
1900s and you had [ __ ] idiot and
imbecile right and those were the three
different categories but then they
became associate created with you know
they you can't use those anymore so then
they they came up with the term mentally
[ __ ] right that eventually now you
can't use that so we move on to
something else and then whatever we're
on now Divergent you're not yeah people
use that in 20 years that's going to be
over yeah that's going to be over too so
we'll find out a new term well well so
neurodivergent is what they use for
mental ailments yeah but the problem
with that is Divergent implies not
normal so you can't say that right I'm
I'm I'm I'm setting it early let's make
neurodivergent extremely offensive
because it implies there are people who
are not normal you're not Divergent you
are the way God created you right
there's no word you can use for anything
where you cannot find something right if
you're one of those people that are
perpetually offended you're going to get
offended by every word that is either in
the dictionary now or will be in the
next you know Millennia my favorite was
uh wimixin and women do you know about
the wimixin thing no so it's woman but
oh yeah yeah instead of En it's xn and
they said the X means it's inclusive of
all women and then people were like what
do you mean inclusive all women women
are women and they're like oh but like
wimix and means you know like women of
color and trans women and then other
leftists were like are you saying that
they aren't women and don't just fall
into the word woman and then fighting
broke out one organ organization said
not using the ax was offensive the other
side using it was offensive then
somebody used an I then somebody was the
Y and then here we are got no idea this
is look this is Idle Hands the Devil's
Playground these people have nothing to
do with their lives they have no skills
no talents no passions so they make up
fake garbage to fight for because they
have nothing else they have no Great War
they have no great challenge that's it
many of them don't have kids if they had
kids they'd be too busy to be doing with
doing these things they need a boogie
man if they don't have a boogeyman they
have no one to fight and since you know
the there's a more demand for for sexism
racism than there actually is a supply
of it and I think that's very clear
especially with this latest uh kind of
uh bastardization of our language
especially when you see just how new
speak it is how orwelling it is exactly
almost from 1984. but but back on the
fetterman kind of topic did you see this
real quick no I did that fetterman
blamed the captioning device oh wow okay
I'm just gonna say it because I I've
been saying this the captioning device
isn't going to work the technology is
not that advanced it is hard for
computers to transcribe Voice to Text
well so I knew this was going to happen
they're blaming it next star came back
out and said hey like we gave you the
special technology you asked for I'm
gonna put it this way fetterman's
campaign said the the captions were
filled with errors right there fill with
errors okay you should not be in that
job because there's no technology better
than the live news captioning system
it's like having someone's blurry vision
be a fighter pilot you wouldn't do it
what was very interesting is seeing
fetterman raise almost a million dollars
from his performance last night I
actually watched Philip DeFranco and he
talked about this he admitted he didn't
do that well but he really wants him to
win that's what he said that Franco said
that saying is wrong with these people
and then DeFranco and Hassan both today
were talking about how horrible Dr Oz is
because Dr Oz didn't allow journalists
to actually record the the the screen
that actually projected the words on
there and they weren't able to fact
check exactly what was on there and it's
Dr Oz that's responsible why is he
responsible that's what they're they're
pointing the finger at him because he
denied uh fetterman to have journalists
looking at the screen to fact check that
it was accurate that's the arguments at
how Cutthroat things are and with the
world sometimes
um I don't know what about like playing
softball for Global political dominance
is not a victory strategy this look I've
been you guys ready you got your shot
glasses ready this is why I've been
talking about Civil War for so long a
sane rational human being is looking at
the facts and saying please I want to be
correct you know what do I if I make a
mistake let me know these people don't
do that for Phil DeFranco to come out
for I'm sorry Phil not just you but for
anyone to come out fetterman actually
didn't it wasn't that bad you know
there's like slate wrote actually
fighterman did pretty well the Philly in
choir saying he did great like yo and
he's saying human watched that and went
wow yeah
without the idea that he had a strong
difference that he didn't do that well
but he's still out of that performance
came out on his show and said I really
hope uh fetterman wins that's my point
they hate you so much facts be damned
they would put a man who can't
understand words can't speak and would
blame his assisted listening device if
it bro if you that they're tweeting out
as a senator all you got to do is say
yay or nay so fireman can do the job
that is not the job of a sender you have
to represent the state to the federal
government they would they are gutting
and burning the system to the ground so
I do not see a scenario where we move
forward as a country when you have these
Psychopaths saying you know what I don't
want to be on the outside and I assume
this is the inside so I'm not backing
away from this we're coming to a point
where it's going to be clear as day with
with all the polling with all the
projections let's assume they're right
maybe they're not maybe maybe Democrats
really are going to win I have no idea
if Republicans do win if and it's a
landslide and we see more of Democrats
agreeing with Republicans and
independents these people still will not
back down because they're in a circular
firing squad as Obama calls it Phil
DeFranco will never admit fetterman
should not be in office and Dr Oz is
tepid at the at the very least he's he's
middle of the road celebrity doctor is
that the worst you could do no there's
worse but he would rather say fetterman
because he knows he's got leftist
activists with their finger on the on
the flag button who are going to ban him
on social media unless he says what they
demand he say I gotta I gotta bring it
back to John fetterman because John you
gotta first of all man heal heal up your
family needs you your wife your kids
they need you man and
you know do your best and if that means
that you need to heal for three years do
it but like it's important to keep the
compassion for John alive we want him to
I want him to be healthy but I also were
voting for a senator right now so let's
put all our cards on the table forget
about the pass look at that debate as is
without knowing any prior he has this
past she has this he has this injury
like fetterman was stuttering and
bumbling and vacant for much of it I
don't want a senator that's stumbling
bumbling and vacant and at one point the
the moderator did say Oz question
question but it was actually meant for
John fetterman and there's a long pause
and John was like oh oh so that's on the
the modern there's one instance where
she said Oz and then asked fetterman the
question and John was really confused
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in Monday through Friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there